ابتداء من العام الجديد ستبدا المشاريع
العملاقه في السعوديه مثل الجديه والبحر
الاحمر بترحي اول منتجاتها السياحيه في
خطوه لا تهم السائحين فحسب بل المستثمرين
ايضا اثناء القمه العالميه للمجلس العالمي
للسفر والسياحه والتي عقدت في الرياض في
نوفمبر الماضي اتضحت الصوره الجديده
للسعوديه في اذان المستثمرين في القطاع
السياحي
القمه العالميه للسياحه وسط تسجيل اكثر من
ثمانيه الاف مشارك من بينهم 250 رئيسا
تنفيذيا لكبر شركات السفر والضيافه عالميا
جوليا سمسم رئيسه مجلس العالم للسفر
والسياحه لا خاصه ما يحدث في السعوديه
قائله انما يحدث من تحول في السعوديه هو
ثمره استثمارات بلغت 800 مليار دولار
والذي يعتبر اضخم استثمارا في تاريخ السفر
والسياحه هذه الاستثمارات الحكوميه التي
تنظمها الاستراتيجيات الوطنيه للسياحه
والتي اطلقت عام 2019 هي مشجع اساسي
لتدفقات رؤوس اموال القطاع الخاص ولكن
استثمارات الحكومه وحدها تكفي وهنا تبرز
اهميه الخطوات التشريعيه والتنظيميه التي
اتخذتها السعوديه لتحفيز القطاع السياحي
ومنها التغيير الشامل في نظام التاشيرات
السياحيه
احد القطاعات الاكثر استفاده من رؤيه
المملكه 20 30 حيث تقدر الوكاله الفراسه
لاستثماريه التي يولدها القطاع السياحي
بين مشاريع وبنيه تحتيه وغيرها باكثر من
500 مليار دولار
وفرت هذه الفرص الاستثماريه حتى ما التوفر
منصه واحده امام المستثمرين من القطاع
الخاص وهو الدور الذي يلعبه صندوق التنميه
السياحي منذ اطلاقه في يونيو الماضي والذي
يعمل على استقصاء برؤوس الاموال الى
القطاع الذي سيضيف عشره في المئه للاقتصاد
السعودي بحلول العام 2030 سعره حمدان
العربيه